[Music]
all right guys i have this
crazy video of these two
women they were kayaking near
some humpback whales off of the beach
near san luis obispo whoa san luis
obispo yes
it's so like a completely different i
was thinking like oh [ __ ] south
america and i'm like oh is that a mexico
city
i don't know how to say it way more
exotic than california
say it again san luis obispo just say
slow
oh thank you yeah exactly san luis
obispo
how do you say it san luis obispo that's
not how we talk
[ __ ] i don't know how to gringo you say
slow though that's what everyone calls
it
slo oh i thought you wanted me to say it
slow if you're like san luis obispo like
that like
what the [ __ ] is gonna be fun like
you know why nikki likes adding like
extending all the words like oh
the reason why i can't gringo fight that
one is because i haven't heard it often
enough in the gringo way
for me to like implant it so i just yeah
cause i don't i never hear you say los
angeles
exactly cause i'm so used to seeing like
los angeles like i know how to agrify
that arcadia
does that even spanish
[Laughter]
pennsylvania
we are all over the place right now
that's how you say it what hollywood
yeah because the double l is like oh
like tortilla
tortilla yeah anyway so tell me once
more
san luis
you sound like those people that go
traveling and you go actually it's
melbourne not
melbourne it's like [ __ ] i'm in america
i'm gonna say melbourne we're in sydney
[ __ ]
yeah but without the actually that's so
funny okay anyway
so these two women they were kayaking
they were watching humpback whales
and there were other people like paddle
boarding and i was like what
people do this i want to do this but
then after watching this video i'm like
maybe not
because they could get flipped over and
that's what happened oh
god you do that on maui all the time so
here i'm going to show you guys this
video
we will try to eat them the l.a beaches
yeah paddleboard and
all that stuff no no wild whale watching
oh no no
no because i've been on like [ __ ] or
whatever the boats the big ass boats
what whale watching here
in long beach yeah but i didn't know
people did this
it that was cool when we were in laguna
beach there was a people kayaking and
then a pot of dolphins was swimming by
them while they were kayaking it was so
cool i'm like how what does that feel
like
i don't know i keep hearing terrible
things about dolphins well like only
they might gang rape you but they
usually mind their own business
most of the time they're helpful and
friendly it's like people
that has a dolphin ever helped you with
oh they help with labor they
help me feel happy
they're always smiling they do cool
tricks and they love doing tricks
they're always smiling every time i see
that it's like people
like most of us are pretty chill but
some are evil
and they might hurt an animal so animals
are like all people
and we're like no not all of us come
here let me hug you
she's advocating for the dolphins yeah
there's there's good dolphins out there
not all dolphins are rapists all right
here we go
pinocchio she was on the kayak you could
tell that lady has big titties
pay attention it's just huge jugs damn
they are huge
they are all right i told you i'm like
of fish where out of my shirt you didn't
even she was on
she was on the kayaks like get these
minorities out of here
she was on the kayak which which all
[ __ ] was on it
both
yeah so both of them were on the kayak
and
when the whale breached they ended up
like
kind of somewhat it looked like it went
inside its mouth but they said that they
were
water for like six seconds and it was
just like they went
under they counted right back up there
was probably a school of fish
under them and they were just scooping
it and it was so that's exactly what
happened and that's what she was saying
at the end
of the video that when they went back to
the car she was like doing this and like
some fish came out
is this technically extreme whale
watching because i think it should
qualify i know
i mean that whale's like you want to see
a [ __ ] whale
dude i know that's why i'm like i gotta
do this in my lifetime
this shit's [ __ ] dope trying to get
eaten by oil yeah if you did it would
you be happier if you got knocked over
would you be happier if you if
it was just to the side of you for sure
to the side but if i ended up getting
knocked
if i had the experience the exact same
you're safe you're safe
it wasn't like 50 feet that's why i said
exact experience that these women had
i'd be pretty thrilled then you'd be on
camera with someone going dad she got
big-ass titties
she didn't even have big-ass titties i
watched it again what
are you what are me what she got big old
i mean
you wish your boobs were like were that
big her tits are like
my [ __ ] wish they look like these are
huge they're gigantic she's probably
like
six feet two but like at the volume the
volume
so what happened was back in her day
they used to sit like this
and then what happens later on in life
they're going to drop down to here each
of her tits is bigger than his [ __ ]
head and she can't handle it
she can't [ __ ] handle i can't handle
it the competition tell by the way it
pulls
the switch it's a sweater because she
looks just like my kindergarten teacher
she had big titties because i
i thought you guys were gonna say like
they're they're like big
like no they're like you could tell like
she has back problems
yeah like when you're sitting at a table
you put them on the table yeah like
that's
she has the lift up no for sure i'm not
saying she has two tiny titties
no you are you called her small you
called her flat you said she's yeah yeah
of course you said those are a's right
that's exactly what i said those look
like triple d's if they exist
yeah so they do triple d like the like
the curvature would be like an
so i thought you guys were saying like
her boobies were like no it comes out
like this yeah
yeah you know they're coming out that's
what probably kept her alive too she was
floating
floating devices that wasn't the one
that got attacked oh i thought they both
went inside
yeah well if the whale made impact with
their titties first
yeah then yeah that would be cool you
know what the conclusion is nobody
listened to anything they were saying
we don't know okay here they definitely
look bigger
in this one because they are like way
from better watching to if any titty
if any titty makes the arm kind of
disappear
that's how you know it's big we went
from talking about humpbacks to hump
fronts and there you go
oh that's nice
yeah you guys didn't even hear what they
said there was there's fish and bones
yeah that's it
she saw the inside of the whale what do
i expect to hear though like we got hit
by the whale man
yeah we went in the water well the other
part that you guys did
was when bart mentioned the boobs was
her saying that the other lady not the
big boo lady but the other lady
that she was like terrified of going
into the ocean that she thought that she
was going to get eaten by a shark and so
the big boob lady ended up convincing
her to
go and do that and then that happens how
big were the other ladies tits
you can't see them we need the real
information we're trying to yeah we're
trying to get all the information
she knew better she was like listen fill
me from right here this is all i want
that's all you see all right you really
can't can you kind of
can you let her talk for a second she's
like people are going to talk about my
tits and then the baby's like no one's
gonna talk nobody's gonna notice
she can't tell from the other you can't
really tell yeah that's really difficult
because she's smart
yeah she's smart she said listen focus
clearly i don't care i'm like it was
worth the shot yeah poor women
just uh i took my niece out in the ocean
like that too on a on a
boogie board because she doesn't really
know how to swim and she's like are you
sure there's no sharks i'm like don't
even trip like it's fine and we went
deep into the water right and we came
back
and then i found out a week ago there
was a tiger shark that bit somebody on
that same beach oh my gosh in hawaii and
tiger sharks don't bite people
they are the ones that bite people
because it gets uh cloudy and muddy in
the water
and they get they come up to shore to
kind of like bite all the turtles and
eat them
and then so when the water's all kicked
up inside they can't really see if it's
a turtle or not they just bite do nurse
sharks bite people
that one is the one that doesn't oh okay
yeah yeah that sounds like a nice shark
yeah like hey i'm here are you okay is
everyone okay i'm gonna give take your
vitals they're the ones that help you
yeah a nurse shark would have some big
titties for sure
with the red cross right there yeah why
did i think you were saying nerf
well because uh i slur my speech a lot
that's why
i swam with sharks when i went to bora
bora i swear
by yourself yeah i'm trying to google
you you were just trying to die on that
trip huh
that was cool it was cool i mean when i
go into the ocean once you go get to a
certain point and you can't see down
it's scary to me i think it's just scary
once you get blue yeah it looks crazy
and there's been times where i've gone
like paddle boarding because like you
were saying they come
you know all the sea life comes close so
even when like a turtle goes swimming
underneath
it's still scary it's super i thought i
saw a shark one time i was swimming to
an island and then i came back
and then um there was a turtle the size
of this table
yeah they're huge i swam next to those
guys when i was scuba diving and it was
sick i slammed with these
oh wow you do deep sea diving i did i
did it in hawaii many years ago and it
was
down he's scuba steve he's actually he's
got a
certified scuba license and for the
longest time we didn't believe him and
then
he had to go get his certification and
then finally prove it
okay explain the breathing part because
first even snorkeling for me freaks me
out a little bit what we call a
regulator oh it's wet
regulator i have no idea i was like what
is this
no what about it though what do you want
to know how do you not panic like how do
you not
freak out you just have to get used to
it in the pool that's why they take you
to the pool
yeah do you breathe out in your mouth
too so you breathe it in your mouth not
your uh out your nose
no no because your nose is sealed from
the goggles damn
otherwise you're going to open your
goggles up and you're going to flood
them yeah
so you need to go that's a good way to
clear your goggles even if you have to
throw up you throw up straight through
your regulator
it's designed for that yeah because you
never want to let you throw you never
wanted to you never want your regulator
to leave your mouth
just in case you can oh you can't go and
then put it back on
you can but it's designed because you're
like disoriented underwater because you
don't know the direction i actually
threw up
not into my regular though but when i
got back i threw up but what about if
you have the big chunky like flaw
noodles in there and stuff it'll still
come out will go through it it'll come
so it's like a blender huh i mean a
garbage dump it'll cut it all up at the
end
the tank air though it feels weird in
your lungs like that like
you did it before well i only did it in
the pool because then
the boat supposedly broke down and we
couldn't go out to the ocean this was in
mexico and i think we got ripped off or
whatever
but we did it in the in the pool and
yeah like that tank air
felt [ __ ] it was helium i know right
you're all high like oh this is not man
it's not
regulated i was like i know this feeling
i loved it because i think you're
getting more oxygen than you normally do
or some [ __ ] i loved it i already know
i'm not built for it
when i'm getting a massage sometimes i'm
like excuse me i can't breathe if you
think about it like under 50 feet under
water and there's
all this water like the sun is this
small right it's a dot
yeah it's scary because you're like [ __ ]
if i run out of air i need
at least 10 seconds total mental before
i so if you think about it it gets scary
and scary i can't breathe right now but
if you're just
chilling then you're not thinking about
it's fun i like to pretend i'm the size
of a clan that is the sickest thing i've
ever done i think
it's scooter diving yeah scooter wow you
know he talks like this but in hanama
bay he was like
is the worst example to give if you
actually know because i was
single-handedly [ __ ] up
like millions of years of marine growth
just chill like just chill don't like
try to step down i was why were you
doing that
because the waves would come and then
his glasses things will get fogged up
but he's like
my [ __ ] was fogged up but okay but the
reason why i was like that is because
if i even move my feet down a little bit
i'm hitting coral because i have the
longest [ __ ] legs
snorkeling in hanama is trash you do not
i did that i love
it i like going there to go snorkeling
you see so much [ __ ]
steve and i would be like this you see
like the biggest [ __ ] fish in the
world like my oh maybe that's why it's
not fun
it's not fine i like my knees boobs
would hit the coral no it was
not it's like [ __ ] you're supposed to
be this way not this way
like keep straight i'm struggling the
flips are upside down
i go underneath and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are we doing
i'm like this this is not how we're
supposed to be doing this
and they're like we don't understand
what you're saying we're looking at your
[Music]
tits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you